Well, I went through a period in life where, you know,
I was the stereotypical Wiebe that didn't go out and I have zero social skills.
And how I learned was I think everyone goes through that stage,
especially if you go through your university where you kind of want to,
you kind of want to reinvent yourself, right.
You move it to someone new and you want to be a new person.
So what I did was I basically just had like a full year where I just
went out as much as possible and talk to as many people as possible,
just like try to go out of my comfort zone.
And that was hell for me as like this introvert, it was kind of like,
it's kind of like a trial by fire period of my life that I would never want to
do. Guess.
300 Spot trainings.
Basically was cause I, I literally, I literally just did not.
Not socialized. I didn't know how to read a room.
I didn't know what the social norms.
That's like such a common,
like cultural thing in Japan that we actually have like our own like phrase for
it, which is university debut. No, really? It's like a,
it's like a cultural thing in Japan where like, because there are so many,
like anti-social kids in middle school and high school and that when they go
into university, they're like, Oh.
I'm like one step closer to where I have to socialize in order to
live in society. So universities,
literally my last chance before I'm thrown into that world.
So I'm going to like make a one 80 during university and just do anything and
everything possible to just completely change myself around, I think.
Oh, P mindset when you, when you, you know,
cause I wasn't cool at all in school,
I was average like very much an in-betweener, you know, I wasn't. Yeah,
but I wasn't like, I wasn't like on the bottom of the social ladder,
if you will like bullied to. Right? I mean that's cause I started fighting back.
I just thought my way out, you know, I was just kinda like whatever,
like no one really paid attention to me. Never had any luck with like, you know,
dating or anything. I never had any of that. But then I thought like, Oh wait,
like no one knows who I am in university. So like, I don't know.
No one knows I'm a mid tier social. I'm a,
I'm a CTO on the social ladder. I can, I can reinvent myself.
And I think I didn't, you know, I didn't reinvent myself. It's just like,
you don't do the mistakes and you don't fall back on crutches that you had like,
like don't, like you said, right. You go out more, you don't, you know,
I could play video games, which I probably would prefer doing.
But if people invite me out, I'll say yes, because you want to be seen.
It was fun. It was fun. Everything goes easier and you learn more,
you get more confident. If for me it was a comfort zone for me, it was like.
The complete opposite.
I was like the really social in middle school and high school.
And then when I entered university, because I started doing YouTube. Yeah.
I like kind of regressed, which socially also lived at home. Right. Yeah.
I lifted, I can imagine that's like Wade, you must feel,
did you feel like different from like the other people who were living on campus.
A little bit. I mean.
Al campus was weird because I think the majority of people in my class did live
at home. Oh wow. Yeah.
We only had maybe like a handful of people who actually lived on campus.
Which, uh, which, which university did you go to again? Uh, Sydney university.
So I guess it's because it's a city university. Yeah.
Have I run campus and like dormitories and stuff like that,
that uni students live in. But I think the majority of people,
because it's such a, uh, an accessible university,
it's like smack bang in the middle of like Sydney, like city.
So people can just like get on trains and buses and just go home.
Yeah.
Because I feel like no one in my class who lived locally to the area really well
that's because.
Swanzey right. And what is there to do in Swanzey? Wow. That's.
A good question. I'm still wondering that myself.
[Inaudible] to be fair.
I didn't live locally. I though I live like an hour and a half by bus,
so I didn't live close at all. I could have, like, I was at a distance way.
I could have easily lived on the dorm,
but then I heard from people who were living in dorms, Edison university,
they were like, don't do it. That's a good experience.
Then being thrown into hell.
Honestly, I,
I feel like I learned more valuable social skills and just life
skills going to university than I did actual career skills that I was
using. That, that I learned from my course.
And I realized it until I left. And then I actually started like functioning.
Yeah. On my own. Yeah.
I don't know what I would have done without that period in my life. Jesus,
that like,
it basically taught me how to survive in the world and how people really
are and all the expectations I had growing up and like, cause,
cause I was a kid. Right.
You kind of expect that as you grow up and the more mature you get,
you assume that everyone's just going to realize what they're doing, get mature.
And then you kind of realize, um, going through university,
especially that that was a lie. And then you go out of university,
start like the working world and you realize, Oh,
everyone here is just like growing up university students and everyone,
nobody actually knows what they're doing.
And everyone is still secretly as immature adults. Aren't as adult,
as I thought they were right now. I don't know.
I feel like I don't it's either like people would just have their together.
Or they don't like it. There's no in between like, I don't know.
I've never met anyone. Yeah.
Most adults that I've met are just like kids in suits essentially.
That's basically the best way I can describe it.